[Music]
we all know that the Olympics got
postponed right for real for real yes
done done so they were gonna have it in
July in Japan but then they took a vote
and seven out of 10 American Olympians
are like Heil nama [ __ ] I'm trying to
do this and then so they also has
Germany they asked people in Poland and
everyone wants to delay it mmm
so now they're gonna have the Tokyo 2020
and 2021 Oh which is crazy because this
is the first time that the Olympics has
ever been postponed or canceled for
something other than war Wow
and the whole world has to come to a
grinding halt because it's over the
coronavirus so they're saying
Korona I know there's over 390,000
confirmed cases of Cova 19 worldwide
with more than 17,000 deaths every
single country has been impacted and I
how many does 17,000 it's been a hundred
thousand that's just in US alone well
that's what this [ __ ] yeah what
is mother formed it probably was written
earlier brah was it let me see old
article we barely there are 17,000 let
me see if there's a more updated
information cuz they might be like
actually it is going on
[Laughter]
and my [ __ ] late ass was like were
catch this [ __ ] you caught it I have
this Twitter account that's like the
Internet Explorer and it's like breaking
news JFK has just been assassinated like
come around now that's where he's
getting his news for me there's a
fourteen-year-old out there that's
Edward yeah somebody shot JFK man that
was me when I opened up the door to all
the conspiracies man I was playing Wow
yeah we're bombing nations that were not
in war with we've been doing that dude
did you know that I knew about heard al
Qaeda when I was in ninth grade and the
world didn't know about al Carmina until
like 11:30 what's the difference between
al-qaeda Taliban and then I guess Isis
they're all different like groups in
yeah do they get along are they home I
don't think so cuz then even like
al-qaeda or like the Taliban maybe those
guys are crazy really
yeah it's like the different cartels
like Isis different factions it was it
so you broke it down for me one time and
I can't remember so it's probably
totally wrong but I thought like Isis
originally was to fight al-qaeda and
that's why we gave them weapons and I
gave al-qaeda weapons to fight the
Russians you could literally tell me
anything and I'd be like oh that's
that's it I'm like oh yeah because the
us hoped Afghanistan I just know the
u.s. helped one group defeat the other
group and the maternal lupus - yeah yeah
so that's all Qaeda Osama's al Qaeda
yeah so then they fun of him and he's
from Saudi Arabia then now and if you
went to Afghanistan and they are already
existed a group called a Taliban there
hmm
all right so I got the actual news
because I went to olympic.org to the
source you know I always got to go to
the source and there's 419 days to go to
the Olympics which means it is gonna be
in 2021
and it's in July 23rd to August 8th does
that mean that we reset the clock now so
now it's like like if let's just cancel
20 20 25 next year's 2020 because they
still have like the construction dates
and they maybe everything I'll push back
for that but they have like set dates
like they know in 2024 or would be
another country maybe no they already
know that already yeah so we're not
gonna push it back a year oh so this is
gonna be everything now it's gonna be
this you're gonna skip a year so it's
gonna go back on Twenty twenty one
twenty four just be three years Dan
which means they only have three years
to change yeah what's up that guy's
plaintiff is so sexy feel like this was
gonna be your last year like you're kind
of getting old right now like this is
like your peak and then next year's not
gonna be your peak like you're one of
those 39 year old now you're gonna be
their last chance to get go Olympic gold
yeah let's [ __ ] up everyone the whole
world
what about elections what if they
postponed that do you think they'll do
that I don't think they will they're not
gonna hate this for right now so mail-in
ballot I don't know I feel like they he
might win again cuz now there's a lot of
people that love them and then there's
also a lot of people on the Democratic
side that hate our candidate that yeah
they're like I'm not gonna vote from
sound like him but they're but I just
went out of say you ain't black yeah
these are only choices right now did he
say nomination dude oh dude so couple
weeks ago it yeah
cancel the 2021 Olympics cuz if we
aren't gonna have a word he had the only
chance man but you know what ended up
happening is all the Grand Boomers and
it got burned he got burned and in the
democratic [ __ ] the the committee [ __ ]
Bernie again I saw Bernie come out and
say that he supports by it in fact we
have to be smart is like hey at least
vote for us still as a group instead of
not voting and basically voting for
Trump
Wyatt keeps having some dyslexia problem
like his he was getting interviewed by
Charlamagne tha God and
like towards towards the end of the
interview like like Charlie Mose
basically asked him I'm like you know
like how are you represented like how
are you helping out black people right
and then he Joe Biden was trying to make
the point that like you know why would
you ever vote for Trump right like I'm
your best bet and then he's like if you
if you're gonna vote for Trump over me
you ain't black I think everybody's like
oh why why if you're not voting if
you're not voting Democrat you ain't
black if you're black and you're not
looking like never getting you ain't
black and it's like that's the thing
about the Democrats is that they like to
play the race card thing and like [ __ ]
man yeah I mean that's I don't like that
I didn't apologize cuz it feels so like
like they're making fun of me
they feels like it's so low to the point
where you need to make me feel like I
have to vote for this team because of my
race not because I'm smart enough to
understand reason yeah I want to know
your policy I don't want to know what
you're gonna do for the country not so
much like playing to my race identity
it sucks cuz if you would have said that
about like Asia blood what it makes me
look better on a boat you know like
now's like oh wait you're not yeah
they're probably gonna vote for him
anyway if they were gonna vote mm-hmm
but I mean that's what they're saying
about people that like that's why I
don't like party politics cuz they're
there is always gonna be a few wedge
issues to like race is usually one of
them women's rights is usually one of
them like abortion or whatever pro-life
or pro-choice and then gay rights was
one of them probably trans rights
something along those lines it's always
like these wedge issues that they go
complete extremism on yeah they hit like
the polls like the extremes of each side
did you see that Trump tweeted out the
the Minneapolis Mayor you pretty much
caught him like a left-wing [ __ ] for
not doing to hold down the city are you
serious I course is gonna burn down cuz
you're a [ __ ] like left Willie ain't
[ __ ] they can't hold a dude or
quote-unquote leaders aren't doing a
good job leading me on it's nuts well
the Olympics just canceled why does that
always happen though like why does it
every time election time comes like
there's nobody where you're like ah this
the guy you know like I want to I want
to Michael Jordan or something I want a
guy that's like yeah now there's two
really good it's like a McGregor and
Mayweather likes some kind of like two
guys up against each other and you're
like [ __ ] yeah yeah it's always like
here's eight you know oh we got hope
drop it under like one of those guys
drop out
yeah it's worse the worst I wonder
someone she's like oh god I think this
last season of The Bachelor did you guys
watch oh like the worst like everyone
tuned out they were like well you might
just pick the too dramatic one I got I
mean that everyone was hot it's so weird
right because when we had the whole
Democratic like primaries there were so
many good candidates I'm like Tulsi
sauce no school she's gonna make him go
hard like yeah she's gonna [ __ ] with
Trump hard right yang doesn't even play
that route so Trump will get tripped up
yeah because he would force Trump to not
to basically think more intelligent and
speak higher right and then Andrew Yang
was it was for the same group of people
that Trump is also for oh yeah little
people yeah yeah that's interesting to
go into debates with now Jaden yeah yeah
didn't Trump talk to young people about
how to coordinate the stimulus checks
yeah that's what I heard cuz he had the
plan for universal basic income and then
it's kind of like resolved yeah he's
doing that like he's doing like a
experiment right like a in a small town
somewhere and I think everyone just gets
500 bucks so I think when he was
pitching though do we move they're
pitching this whole theme we're like
where people like we're like well we
don't know you know we know it's in
Alaska but we don't know how it's gonna
do here how that affects the economy so
he's like I want to do a small little
case study I forgot which city like
Rochester or some [ __ ] Rochester then
he's giving you raised like five enough
for people to get 500 bucks a month to
see what the actual effects are if crime
decreases order who prosper you know
it's funny is that all these people that
were against it they're getting the
checks now and it's like they're seeing
how it benefits them and [ __ ] and then
they're like that's so funny drew was
honest on to you the checks are cool I
mean the checks our dog is like my
haven't asked me for money in two months
I was like oh [ __ ] y'all look good right
now good I'm wondering like what that's
gonna do to Social Security I mean
Social Security was already [ __ ] but
now I like is it doubly [ __ ] like
what's gonna happen like you think it's
a train it's coming from the same funds
yeah I mean it has to do right like
that's where the government gets the
money from so damn who knows I did see
this article where the feds uncovered a
300 million dollar unemployment scam so
man they're getting hella sophisticated
right and it's coming from a lot of West
African nations like there's you know
how like we had the Nigerian scammers
right but they're getting really [ __ ]
good at this we're basically you know
that whole data hack that happened to
Experian and all that yeah so now all
that like is out you could buy that [ __ ]
you could buy identities all that right
so like now scammers from there and all
over the world are using that database
to pretend to being certain Americans
and they can sign up and doing all that
stuff right yeah and then so now they're
sending out these different types of
phone calls and emails and whatever that
are job recruiting so they'll be like
hey amazon is offering $400 a week like
to work from home and you can do all
these things and so people are like I'll
[ __ ] you I need a job right so they sign
up for this and then they send a check
and then it's like 3000 bucks and then
they split this check up and they say
put it here put it there sign up for
this thing whatever and what they're
what they're basically doing is they're
stealing this dude's identity they're
getting all this information they're
filing for unemployment they're getting
these like accounts like just
maneuvering all this [ __ ] it's like
super sophisticated and then they're
basically checking the unemployment
money or like cashing that [ __ ] out on
behalf of you guys hmm it's not and then
these guys think they're getting a job
right and in the check bounces and they
moved all this money for for the
scammers and they're like where's my job
down and they they basically so far they
got back 50 million but I think this was
just Washington State alone wait how
much did they scam
I think so 3 million but all 300
nationwide or that will stay but they so
far got back 50 mils yeah what are these
guys they're like living in like in
palaces what to do with the money I
think it's like a worldwide thing of a
bunch of people doing it in volume so
it's not like one group or one person
yeah kind of like like Nigerian Prince's
right there's so many Nigerian Prince's
this is one of the main like languages
out there yeah yeah I didn't even know I
was watching the 90 day fiancé
and one of the dudes is Nigerian rapper
named Soulja Boy and so jib when I sold
your boy soulja boy purpose I don't know
man but he has he's probably an actual
soldier a soldier soldier soldier so
he's and he's like he's married to this
like older white chick but um they were
saying that like English is one of the
main languages out there like oh I had
no idea
I saw the part where they bought a goat
and she thought she was like am I
getting the white price or am I getting
is not she's getting like bamboozled
instead he's like no no ready this is
the precious just shut up and get the
goat yeah
[Music]
[Music]